Imran Khan, a cricket star turned politician, is Pakistan's likely next Prime Minister.
Khan has used an anti-corruption platform to build a mass following, but he has hardly gotten to where he is on his own.
Khan's main opponent,
former Prime Minister Nawaz Sharif,
was thrown out of office in 2017 on dubious charges by the Supreme Court.
Since then, he has received a 10-year prison sentence for corruption
and was arrested along with his daughter and political heir Maryam Nawaz Sharif.
Nawaz Sharif has been a vocal critic of Pakistan's army.
Many believe that the army worked to throw him out and promote its preferred candidate, Imran Khan.
Khan's use of the army to get elected does not bode well for Pakistan's ailing democracy.
His worldview combines socialism and Islamism.
He blames America for Pakistan's terrorist problem, supports fundamentalist positions, and wants Pakistan to be an Islamic welfare state.
With a struggling economy and decaying international reputation,
Pakistan needs introspection. Imran Khan represents a doubling down on denial.
What do you think about Imran Khan? Will he weaken or strengthen Pakistan's democracy?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.